my mouth cannot like do that we're here
testing community user-submitted
McDonald secret menu basically stuff
that people made up I only eat
McDonald's when I'm like oh let's make a
drunk decision Oh McDonald's yeah sure
they have garlic fries now just look
like regular fries they look a little
crispier Cheers
Oh broke his hoof I give it a weight I
don't like the smell oh yeah throw up I
think someone was very high when they
made this no this is amazing oh my god
this is a full course meal in one
sandwich I'm expecting like an Egg
McMuffin and then I'm just like
bombarded with sugar amazing that's
happiness in a cup this tastes like cold
stone but cheaper because the whole
McFlurry just tastes like apple pie
it's kind of cool they should sell this
market it McDonald's what are you doing
ice creams already sweet enough but then
apple pie mixed in it's just just too
much I don't know I make flurries are
pretty good especially for all the
effort involved in making this I'd
rather just get a normal McFlurry
[Music]
this sounds like heads really good look
at all this mail that's too much Mayo I
hate mail ok so that's what I'm not
loving the sauce overpowers will make
chickens are perfect so I don't know why
you would mess with that but actually
this is better than a regular make
chicken this is an onion sandwich oh my
god no great what I only toast bread and
lettuce there's even me oh yeah the
vegetarian people highly recommend this
[Music]
this looks fake you like prepare myself
for this oops
I taste spicy but then I taste the fur I
don't know what to I don't know how to
describe this I would just rather eat
like this by itself and maybe then I
would go and eat the chicken watch you
need to eat three burgers at one time
I'm like daddy's of burgers right here
and it's gonna fall apart like you can't
eat this while driving with one hand
stop you should be eating driving with
one hand honestly I had very low
expectation so the secret menu exceeded
those it was very creative so my daddy
burger a plus I feel like the secret
menu is just people my thoughts at this
point because it's like why mess up the
fries and why put three sandwiches
together as one how do I turn into
proteins peanut butter oh how this is
like happy